one of the most important choices you
will make in a boarder lands game is
picking your vault hunter we're happy to
inform you that we think every vault
hunter in Borderlands 3 is a ton of fun
and you can't really go wrong with any
of them that said they are designed
differently around specific play styles
in this video we're going to give you an
overview of each character so you can
pick which vault hunter is right for you
let's start with Amara
if you liked playing as brick in
Borderlands or Krieg in Borderlands 2
you'll most likely enjoy Amara as she's
basically the siren equivalent of those
two put together though she does come
with some support and defensive
abilities Amara is almost entirely
offense based and at her best when she's
in the middle of a fight
punching bandits with her fists and
crushing soldiers with her elemental
arms if you want to be aggressive like
all the time then you want to pick Amara
each of Omar's three active skills are
designed to get her into an opponent
space as quickly as possible
many of them can be evolved with
secondary perks to aid Amara in close
quarters combat like keeping her
elemental arms out to deflect bullets or
extend the reach and power of her melee
attack as Amara you're always charging
forward as her power attack grows when
closer to an enemy so if you pick Amara
you'll always want to be surrounded this
requires good spatial awareness there's
a lot to account for when multiple
enemies are hitting you from more than
one direction shotguns and close-range
pistols are your best friends if you
enjoy tossing grenades and sniping
enemies from a distance then Amara is
not for you Amara is a bit more
difficult to use in comparison to her
fellow vault hunters as a result of her
emphasis on overwhelming her opponent
with close quarters elemental damage
some late-game
enemies and bosses can fly or have
sturdy elemental resistances both of
which put Amara at a disadvantage you
may want to hold off on picking her for
your first playthrough if this is your
first Borderlands game but if you think
guns are silly and you rather just punch
every enemy to death then look no
further than Amara next up is Zane who
is a hit and run character and a grenade
stacking maniac with the right digi
clone build
unlike other vault hunters he can use
two skill trees at once however there is
no reason to do so in your early
playthrough due to the second skill
taking the place of grenades Oh glorious
grenades part of what makes aim such an
effective hit-and-run tactician has to
do with his potential to explode
everything in the immediate area and
then instantly teleport out this power
comes from the digi clone the digi clone
is one of the same skill trees that
allows him to summon a stationary copy
of himself
Zain can swap places with the Colonna
any time and even use the clone to
revive from fight for your life state
mid tree the clone can be used
creatively to bound up a battlefield
fallback to the load or simply as a
distraction to draw fire as a neces down
the tree several abilities begin to
vastly increase explosive power such as
fractal frags where the clone throws a
copy of your grenade there's also duct
tape mod where Zane will randomly fire
grenade binary system which causes the
clone to release a cryo Nova when places
are swapped and doppelganger where the
clone explodes at the end of the skill
timer combining these abilities with any
grenade that has an mir v trait which
splits into multiple munitions or even
better one that splits into multiple
sticky shot traps Zane's biggest danger
is actually himself it's important to
leave an area that's been blanketed with
grenades either by leaving the digit
clone behind or with prodigious running
if you want a completely different same
one that posts up behind a barrier and
sun's out a drone to flush enemies from
cover then his other two skill trees
barrier and Sentinel make him into bless
of a solo build and more of a support
team player you can even pick up and
move with his shield but if you're
looking for someone a little more
hot-headed Mo's is perfect for series
newcomers and highly recommended to
those with an itchy trigger finger on
her own she doesn't have much combat
abilities but when you jump into her
iron bear mech a world of possibility is
available to you the iron bear is only
available for a limited time but in that
short duration it's well capable of
wiping out entire rooms of enemies it
starts with three weapons the V 35
grenade launcher the minigun and the
railgun but that Arsenal expands
by investing in each of Moses three
skill trees opening up options to equip
other types of firepower like a
flamethrower and a rocket volley and
each can also be customized the skills
that modify their capabilities the iron
bear can be used in a variety of
strategic ways you can summon it
frequently to rain down everlasting hell
upon your enemies or you might just keep
it as your ace in the hole during boss
fights or when a fire fight goes south
Hecky can take both approaches it's up
to you
Moe's can also be useful as a tank
conceptually and literally for other
players after all the iron bear is a
near invincible wall that can easily
pull enemy aggro off teammates none of
this is to say that Moe's isn't capable
outside the MEK in fact she's just as
deadly on foot her skill tree has plenty
of bonuses that amplify her capabilities
such as improved reload speed bonus and
sendiri damage and enhanced shield
strength many of Moses skills optimize
her ability to inflict damage as
aggressively as possible while
occasionally buffing teammates and even
letting them hop aboard the iron bears
man to turret as Moe's you are regularly
switching between wiping out enemies on
foot and devastating them with the iron
bear
she's a scrappy agile and adaptable
character whose most significant
strength is stacking up a plethora of
damage in a short time and taking the
heat off friends in many ways Moe's is
essentially a titanfall pilot without
the wall running so if that doesn't make
you want to play as her then we don't
know what does now Moses Lee works great
when playing well with others but say
you want to play the game solo well in
that case you'll want to go with flack
every vault hunter is perfectly viable
to play with solo but in many ways flack
is designed around working by themselves
instead of real friends you can make up
the difference with one of flax 3 pets
not only do their kills count for
getting a second chance of you're down
but you can eventually invest in a
passive skill that lets them straight up
revive you real friends who needs them
each pet behaves differently and can be
swapped around at any time allowing for
a lot of experimentation in which pet
you prefer the master tree is all about
boosting the pets but even if you don't
spec in this tree it's important to
understand that flax pets are a key part
of their rhythm of play and if you
aren't using them all the time then you
aren't taking full advantage of what
flack can do
as for flack themselves there's a lot of
DNA from previous vault hunters Mordecai
and Xero and flax other skill trees fade
away lets you turn invisible for a short
period and raccattack throws out a group
of rax to assault enemies so yeah if you
like those characters flak will be very
familiar to you and also like those
characters Black is best suited for
long-range sniping there
your skill tree is all about increasing
crit damage so if you like playing from
a distance using sniper rifles and
getting headshots then flak is for you
Jacobs guns which are all about
bolt-action precision damage are gonna
be your best friends black is gonna work
best for players that manage their pets
along with their own skills and team up
on enemies to take them out together
they may not be as visually flashy as
the other vault hunters but make no
mistake in the hands of a skilled player
flack can dish out some serious damage
my one warning for picking flak is that
their pets do tend to walk in front of
you during important emotional moments
with characters which can be annoying we
hope you found all this information
helpful in deciding which vault hunter
you want to roll with first once you've
made your choice why not watch our
specific tips and build loadouts for
each character which are on the way
thanks for watching and we hope you have
a great time with your chosen vault
hunter